est-ce qu'on ait pour autant sur que
tout cela n'était pas fabriqué pour
qu'ensuite ils viennent en france sous
couvert d'être un opposant pour pouvoir
déstabiliser le candidat moi la
république or marche à la mairie de
paris après tout ce sont des gens quand
même très sérieux qui ont évoqué un
complot russe du mans je pense que tous
les jours il n'est pas question de ne
pas en parler mais je pense que vladimir
poutine
tous les jours depuis bonne dizaine
d'années d'ailleurs se réveille en
disant mais griveaux c'est insupportable
ça va être le leader du monde occidental
et trouvez moi des stratégies pour
l'abattre parce que cet homme est trop
puissant trop intelligent son aura va
irradier le monde moderne et on va
passer de la bipolarité au
multilatéralisme et donc il a mis en
place tout le fsb tous les oligarques
qui se sont ligués contre lui qui enfin
l'ont fait chuter après 18 cm d'efforts
consentis à un moment un moment pour
accompagner des histoires qu'on veut ça
ne tient pas la route
une demi seconde c'est grotesque non
mais ça tient à bien cette voie c'est
tragique et le président la rivière qui
aimait cette hypothèse qui met le feu
aux poudres mais qui ne savaient pas
autre chose même manoeuvre de 10 ans fin
pour moi c'est un garçon de 3 ans et
plus et alain duhamel aura des gens
vivants attendait excusez moi c'est
peut-être alain duhamel mais quand le
prisme la république quand même les
prisons la république reprend à son
compte cette suggestion réellement c'est
qu'on est on est vraiment dans la laure
lui andy hall dans le cadre de la nive
au moral et du dip fake et c'est
grotesque et c'est guignol est
mais le vrai problème c'est que c'est
coton indécent sûr que qui est une
explication enfin n'importe quelle
politique officielle puisse avancer
cette théorie là c'est vraiment prendre
les gens pour des cons et c'est vraiment
indécent parce que c'est absolument et
surtout depuis introuvable une ce qui le
type c cloud et les couilles sur la
place rouge
et on ose dire que c'est un agent de
poutine déguisé c'est absolument
indécent ça que au delà de grotesque
c'est indécent c'est pas possible c'est
obscène d'oser dire ça et d'essayer de
tous ses effets et puis après on a
trouvé la parade c'est l anonymat vous
savez tout le monde s'est mis en ordre
de marche
mais d'abord ils ont cherché un peu ils
ont tâtonné quand
mais qu'on puisse même avancé cette idée
mais c'est quand on est en
responsabilité politique
on peut pas faire ça c'est pas possible
c'est complètement indécent si quand on
n'a pas envie qu'on parle encore de la
réforme des retraites on n'a pas envie
de parler des violences policières de la
manière dont les choses se passent
aujourd'hui en france comment il ya un
démantèlement de l'état social
oui on parle de ce genre
[Musique]